[музика]
Привіт усім з вами пані Ліда і
ведмежатко бо Привіт Ми продовжуємо
вивчати нашу абетку і сьогодні у нас 10
літера і Літера називається
The подивись веду жатку як вона виглядає
І на що вона схожа
літера з друзів дуже схожа на якусь
цифру Чи здогадаєтесь ви на яку
справді на цифру три Ось Подивіться вони
справді близнючки літера З і цифра три
Зараз ми з вами
подумаємо які слова починаються з літери
з або звука з
подумаємо ведмежатко наприклад з зайченя
з замок
що це замок це така будівля де можна
жити або інше слово замок
це такий пристрій що допомагає закривати
і відкривати двері
йдемо далі з зошит
зупинка ведмежатко думайте
зуби у молодець вірно всіх нас є зубки з
зима
з зірка
з знак наприклад дорожній знак який
допомагає дотримуватись правил
дорожнього руху Так А ще є імена на
літеру з або звук з
з
зимовій з Захар
А ти знаєш якісь імена на літеру з
Так я знаю я колись Був знайомий з
дівчинкою на ім'я
Злата у молодець Так це ім'я теж
починається з літери з і звука з
Гаразд Друзі а тепер ведмежатко ми
напишемо з дітками літеру з А зараз
Приготуйте пальчики розімніть собі їх
порухайте трішки ними
і ми напишемо літеру з
увага зверхньої крапочки верхня півколо
і нижня півколо
молодці ще раз верхня півколо і нижня
півколо супер потренуйтесь собі вдома
писати літеру з молодці а зараз
послухайте будь ласка про літеру з такий
віршик ведмежатко слухаю бажано і ваша
буде завдання порахувати скільки літер Z
ви нарахуєте у ньому
збоку знизу і згори схожа зе на цифру
три
є три зуби в букви з ними все вона гризе
Ось така весела буква з Ось вона має три
зубчики один два три і справді дуже
подібна на цифру три
А скільки ж літер з ви нарахували у
цьому віршику
його ви бачите на екрані
порахуйте ведмежатко Ти теж порахуй будь
ласка Так здається я вже порахував
Скільки ж у тебе вийшло
[музика]
7 чи 8 не можу зрозуміти вірна відповідь
8 8 літер з є у цих всіх словах Гаразд
друзі А для чого ми вчимо літери Як ви
думаєте
вірно ми вчимо літери для того щоб
навчитися швидше читати адже читати так
цікаво можна дізнаватися про щось нове
читати казочки оповідання Це так класно
проводити час просто супер друзі А ви
знаєте що літера З і звук зе звук це
приголосний звук що це означає це
означає що ми його вимовляємо з
перешкодою не так як голосні що ми
можемо їх проспівати А нам Щось заважає
А ну ми вимовимо його з з нам заважають
зубки Ми не можемо його просто
проспівати
А зараз Ми вже вивчили з вами голосні
літери і приголосну з
і ми разом з ними з цими голосними
складемо з вами склади адже ви
пам'ятаєте що таке склад це одна голосна
і приголосні отже
літера З
А це що за літера
літера а і в нас складеться склад
ведмежатко Ану ми прочитай
за вірно молодці друзі Тепер ви за гарно
приголосно з ми залишимо І добавимо
голосну що це за буквочка
е молодці а тепер прочитаємо разом
ведмедику допомагай
зе Молодець ведмедику ти навчився читати
гарно тепер поміняємо голосну
наступна голосна ми її теж вже знаємо
Нагадайте мені друзі
це літера є вірно молодці і ми
добавляємо її до нашої буквочки з і
утворимо склад
є вірно ведмедик ось ми вже з вами
навчилися читати склади з цієї літерою А
зараз будь ласка послухайте наша
улюблена рубрика загадки
Куций хвостик довгі вушка шерсть
м'якенька як подушка скаче вгору наче
м'ячик Хто це діти сірий хто такий
сіренький скаче вгору наче м'ячик хто це
хто Це хто здогадався говоріть голос
вірно це зайчик супер молодці друзів Ну
раз ми згадали за зайчика ми зараз з
вами дещо зробимо цікаве Подивіться будь
ласка у мене тут є зайченята оцей зайчик
якої форми
вірно цей зайчик круглої форми а ось у
мене ще є один кумедний зайчик
Подивіться А цей якої форми
трикутної тому що він має в своїй основі
трикутник три кути і три сторони Скажіть
будь ласка А скільки у зайчика лапок
вірно чотири А скільки вушок
вірно два вушки у зайчика ось цей
круглої форми а цей зайчик трикутної
форми і ми виберемо яку морквину до
кожного зайчика нам треба дати
подивіться у мене тут є морвочки круглої
форми
Ось і морквочки трикутної форми
трикутник
[музика]
гарно і кожен зайчик отримує морквину
своєї форми Отже до зайчика круглої
форми ми будемо давати круглі морквинки
і будемо їх рахувати отже
один
два
[музика]
три Ось зайчик у нас отримав три
морквинки добре буде куштувати їх
смакувати Адже всі зайці люблять
морквини ви це знаєте точно тепер у нас
є зайчик якої форми
трикутної вірно і отримує морквинки
трикутної форми також один рахуйте
і ще одна морквинка остання
три три морквинки у цього зайчика і
[музика]
три морквинки у другого зайчика
Підкажіть будь ласка скільки всіх
морквинок ми віддали зайцям скільки їх
усіх
Нумо порахуємо 1 2 3 4 5 6
морквинок усіх молодці друзі зайців ми з
вами нагодували А зараз наступна загадка
будьте уважні у савані проживає
[музика]
чорно-білі смужки має і весела і пригожа
на конячку нашу схожа Хто це ведмедику
Як ти думаєш
так друзі молодці це зебра вірно і
давайте складемо слово зебра із наших
літер перша літера у нас Z
друга
е
наступна ми вже її знаємо друзі в
наступне
р
і остання нам всім відома літера
А
ось і склалося слово зебра
це слово має дві голосні літери давайте
їх проспіваємо
А
молодці правильно Супер А скільки усіх
літер у слові зебра порахуймо
ведмедику
допомагай один два три чотири п'ять
літер вірно 5 літер і 5 пальчиків на
руці
молодці а зараз друзі у нас з вами гра
Ви вже вмієте в цю гру бавитись я зараз
буду називати слова а ви Приготуйте
долоньки якщо ви почуєте слова де є звук
з
то ви маєте плеснути у долоні готові
ведмежатко А ти готовий добре приготуйся
отже
заєць
[музика]
вірно молодці
слон Ні не блискаємо звука з тут немає
зебра
є молодці плеснули
візок
плескаємо молодці
Земля
є чую ваш плескіт квітка
Ні не плескаєм вірно
змія
плескаємо у долоньки зайченя
[музика]
і знову плескіт
Тіна
Ні не бласкаємо
і останнє слово зірка
плескаємо молодці Ну що ж ви були великі
молодці зробили Сьогодні усі завдання
відгадали загадки вдома потренуйтесь
писати літеру з та шукайте її у
книжечках А нам ведмедику час прощатись
Дякуємо що були з нами на все добре До
нових зустрічей па-па
Привіт Привіт друзі з вами юстинка і
Пані Настя ми дуже раді вас бачити
хочемо з вами вивчити і заспівати пісню
про ведмедика який їхав у машині а для
того щоб їхати в машині треба в ручки що
взяти кермо кермо Там ми будемо їхати на
машині Ось так у ліс В ліс Та і поїхав
Ведмідь за малину давайте з вами вивчимо
ці рухи і слова
сів ведмедик у машину та й поїхав
помалину а в Малині джміль бринить і
злякався наш ведмідь Ой це звір такий
носатий і сердитий покажіть які ви
сердиті можете бути і
крилатий він якщо нас дожене візьмемо і
тепер їмо малинку з'їсть малину і мене
окей Ось така пісенька А тепер Давайте
спробуємо заспівати її трошечки швидше
готові
поїхали баран берем кермо і їдемо в ліс
всі ведмедику машину та й поїхав по
малину а в Малині дж Добрий день і
злякався наш ведмідь Ой це звір такий
носатий і Сердитий і крилатий він Якщо у
нас дожене з'їсть малину і в мене ось
такий страшний звір який налякав
великого ведмедика
[музика]
це звір маленький
ви разом вас бачити Сподіваюся вам дуже
сподобалось Наша пісенька А тепер Настав
час прощатися па-па
[музика]